we are now joined by magnus carlsen the
first match in the final is higher than
minus i have to tell you we're very
surprised about your
tactics in this final game a draw here
what was that all about
um i felt like [ __ ] and i didn't want to
play
okay what do you mean if i felt like
[ __ ] your form
yeah i was just um yeah i don't
i don't feel good today hopefully i'll
feel better tomorrow
all right so banking everything on
tomorrow uh
then no it's not about banking
everything on tomorrow it's just that
i don't i think if you if you don't feel
well you
should listen to your your body
absolutely magnus uh if you're still not
feeling great tomorrow
will you continue with the same strategy
will you um try to force yourself out of
this funk somehow
uh yeah we'll see you tomorrow hopefully
i'll uh
hopefully get better but if i can ask
you just one question then about
the game that you won because that was
quite spectacular how did you feel about
that
no i mean
i think i reacted kind of poorly at the
ice idea in the opening and then
um i don't know he went wrong at some
point and
i got a bit lucky so i'm overall
not not dissatisfied with with
the overall result obviously it's a pity
to
to play as poorly as i did in the in the
third game but
um yeah it happens so um
overall i should be you should be
relatively satisfied with that with the
draw
all right and well with uh not feeling
well
today and and also with the history
against wesley in the finals how do you
sort of see your chances of now
winning the fdx crypto cup no it depends
on
tomorrow if i feel if i feel
okay tomorrow i have every chance of
winning all right well minus
uh definitely we wish you some good rest
and hope you're feeling better tomorrow
thanks for joining us
thank you